paganism is coming back the paganism
that you don't really notice where you
just
start to worship money and you start to
worship sex and you start to worship all
the created things of this world
celebrity and you don't really notice it
also overt paganism is coming back also
steeped in Tradition kind of paganism
nature worship polytheism that is coming
back in a pretty conscious way as well
and the reason for this is that we've
kicked Christianity out of the Public
Square
and this has happened not only because
of the faithlessness of of the members
in the church but also because leftist
activists have booted it out using the
law using political activism from the
Public Square so when you don't let kids
learn the Bible in schools when you
don't let people pray in schools when
you instead when you replace the Bible
with pornography in schools as we're
seeing today that's going to change
people's formation